so this is gonna be a little different
than some of the other talks it's not
focusing on specific technology what
will happen is that you'll often use
packages and tools but what's really
important to do is understand what those
tools are doing under the hood I'm gonna
show you an example of a really cool
kind of concept called hidden Markov
models and we're gonna build it up from
scratch I'm gonna have a little bit of
Python code to show that you can
implement it in just a few lines you
wouldn't do that in practice but it's
good to know that when you do like
import hmm or something like that what
that's doing under the hood okay a
little bit about myself so I work at
LinkedIn right now I graduated from UC
Berkeley at Berkeley that's where I
learned first about hidden Markov models
and actually what was happening was
somebody I was helping somebody
understand something called dynamic
programming I'll get to that and they
asked what are some useful applications
of that concept and I found I realized
that what I learned at Berkeley well
that was a great application of it okay
so what are the goals just want to set
some expectations so that nobody's
disappointed first of all we're gonna
introduce this concept of hidden Markov
models okay we're gonna use this concept
of dynamic programming which like I said
I'll explain more about what exactly
that is to see how we can use hidden
Markov models to make predictions and
then we'll do some overview of some
places where hidden Markov models are
used in the real world and that's where
we'll talk a little bit about the
training part of it I don't want to get
too deep into the training part of it
because that's another it's basically
another talk and I would love to deep
dive into it some other time okay so
let's start with the motive motivating
example and by the way all of this will
build up on its
so if there are questions I would love
to make sure they're clarified before
moving on but the motivation for this is
gonna be speech recognition right so you
have this kind of waveform that's coming
in to you and there's these chunks and
we want to map them to syllables so
dynamic right in a sense we have our
things that we are taking in as input
the waveform and our output the actual
syllables that represent what those
waveforms mean right so the way we
represent that as a hidden Markov model
is as follows we start with things
called States States are the ground
truth okay so in this case it would be
like dynamic right they form this chain
okay we'll get into some properties of
these that are really important for how
we use this but these are called hidden
states and the reason they're called
hidden States is because for each of
those states that you're in you're going
to emit some kind of observation okay so
for the first syllable die there could
be many different observations that we
could see different people will talk
about spell out that syllable in
different ways
and there's some kind of probability so
basically there's a whole set of
different waveforms we might look at
some of those are likely to be emitted
from die some from na some from Mik but
all of those have probabilities of being
emitted from each of those states and we
only observe the actual observations the
states that are underlying them are
hidden we don't know what they are okay
some properties of this hidden Markov
model and we start off with what's known
as an initial probability so that says
that what is the probability of getting
into a particular state from the get-go
okay
so way we would think about this for the
speech recognition example is
what are people likely to start off by
saying right
not all syllables are as likely to start
off a chunk of text or touch chunk of
speech let's say there's also transition
probabilities so going from one state to
another so I'm going from die to na
there is some probability of doing that
but going from two completely unrelated
syllables that never show up in English
next to each other very low probability
you know close to zero
and there is such a probability for
every pair of states and what's
important here you notice is that the
boxes for the transition probabilities
are on individual arrows so the real
important property that makes these
Markov models is that the transition
from one state to another only depends
on the starting state and where you end
up it does not depend on the entire
history that is a limitation there are
for example generalizations where you
might look at the last two or three
states but generally it doesn't turn out
to be that big of a problem and it
simplifies our problem a lot okay and
finally the last parameter of our hidden
Markov model is the emission probability
so again given a particular syllable
what is the what probability do you have
of emitting a particular waveform okay
and that exists for every pair of state
and emission are there any questions on
this so these are the parameters of our
hmm and here's the problem that we want
to solve so we have some kind of hmm
with these three parameters and we have
a sequence of emission so in this case a
bunch of waveforms like chunks of
waveforms one after the other and what
we want to calculate is what is the most
probable sequence of hidden states that
resulted in those emissions so what was
the ground truth there could be multiple
ground troops for a particular set of
waveforms but
what is the most probable one right well
that's the fundamental thing we want to
solve for why is this this hard problem
at all well let's take a look so maybe
we're inferring some syllables and where
we are is ah okay terr okay that's what
it sounds like great and keep going mo
Beale okay
the problem is we thought based on maybe
the way somebody was talking the first
two syllables were otter but really it
was Otto right and we didn't know that
until we got later in the sequence so
somehow we have to predict into the
future what's going to be the actual
waveforms that are going to come up
later and if you think about that how
are we gonna predict the future so
that's why this is a non-trivial problem
what we're gonna do is we're gonna look
at it a little differently right so
right now the problem was in the kind of
where the critical Junction was where we
had to make the choice we were inferring
a bunch of syllables and then we had to
make a decision are we going into aw as
an O or oo as an au and we don't know
until later which one was the right
choice but somehow we've kind of let
ourselves be put into a particular path
without knowing how this path will
affect us later right we're gonna flip
it now we're gonna say let's look at
every possible state or a sequence of
ground truths we could have had and then
later when we have more information
choose one of those to continue okay so
now we're not saying here's the best
path I have so far how do I continue
forward it's I have all these paths from
before which one do I continue right
it's a little abstract
but framing it in this way will help us
formulate an actual algorithm for
solving this problem so what we're gonna
do to make this concrete is define this
this function write V and the reason
this is called V is because this is the
Viterbi algorithm okay and it says that
at time T what if we ended up at state X
what's the probability of that we could
have taken any path it doesn't matter
what path we took to get to that point
so that's for example saying what's the
probability of ending up at verses toe
right so that's the basic idea if it's a
little abstract let's define how we
would actually calculate this and it'll
make more sense so if we want to talk
about the very first time step right we
have we want to say what if we ended up
at state s and we had Y as our omission
well what's the probability of that
happening we need two things to happen
first we need to have ended up in state
s in the first place and that's defined
by our initial probability and we needed
to have emitted Y from state s and again
because of the Markov property and
generally about hmm s the emission
probability was not dependent on how we
got there so these are independent we
multiply them together so this is for T
equals 0 for any given the ending state
at the first time step okay any
questions with this part yeah now what
if we're in the middle of our sequence
right some arbitrary time T well first
of all we could have come from a bunch
of other previous steps it doesn't
matter how we got to those steps but we
were at some step R at time t minus 1
and we need to know what was the
probability of getting two that are ok
at that time
then we needed to transition from our
into s doesn't matter how we got to our
but going from R to s is one of the
transition probabilities right and we
want the maximum probability right so we
look at all the possible previous States
and maximize this quantity over that
okay and finally we still need to omit Y
from that last step okay does that make
sense to people okay so that just gives
us this is just summarizing what I said
right so you have something for t equals
zero and for any arbitrary T after zero
there's a couple of things that we
should notice about this well first of
all the inputs are basically integers
now granted the second input is really a
state but there's a finite number of
them you can assign a number and integer
to them so there's 0 through some some
number right and then the time steps are
also discrete secondly the the function
depends on itself it's a recursive one
so it's called a recurrence relation
okay
now if we were to just try to evaluate
this well we'll see is that we would end
up calculating the same things again and
again right we might if we go back to
something like this right what are we
coming from it doesn't matter what s
were going to we would have to look at
the same ours again and again and again
and that would just be a waste of
computation time so that's where the
fact that our our inputs are integers
really comes in handy we can lay out all
the different values for T in this kind
of table and that says that when one
axis we have the time steps on access
the different states okay so this is
just a two-dimensional table we just
need to fill this out and we can fill it
out in kind of a smart order okay so we
know that at time T equals 0
there's no dependencies right
we don't we can calculate those without
needing any other values prior to it we
just need to know the hmm parameters any
questions about that then for one of the
next one of the elements in the next
time step right we need to look at all
the previous states so we're gonna
depend on all the previous states but
that's okay we just computed everything
on the previous time step and that's the
basic idea you just gonna go through
column by column filling out this table
okay this will give you all the values
of V now can anybody tell me how much of
this table we need to keep in memory at
a time
any idea is one column right so you
compute one column the first column then
you use that to compute the next column
and then you can throw away the first
column and then you compute the next Oh
unfortunately the real world isn't that
nice because we have to do one more
thing right at the end what you'll have
is these V values what are the V values
again they're probabilities what was the
probability that you ended at a
particular step at the very end
right and that's great you could take
the maximum such probability but you
still need to figure out what states got
you to that probability right so we're
gonna store some pointers back to when
we did that maximization step that said
here are some R's we're looking at what
are led to this highest probability
we're gonna keep a little reference
saying oh we came from this R in order
to get this highest probability and so
for that reason we do have to keep the
entire table in memory that's a great
question so the question is like why
can't we just keep track of just the
linked list that results in the highest
probability right the problem is until
you get to the very end you don't know
what's your last what's the maximum in
the very last column
so there's multiple paths through this
table and there's multiple link lists
through this table and you're only gonna
pick out one of them but you don't know
that until you get to the very end does
that make sense just imagine right like
the top right cell pointed to point it
through a different path through this
table right and that ended up being the
very maximum probability that would be a
different path but you wouldn't know
that until the very end we can also talk
about this later one thing I want to
point out we started with a mathematical
definition we visualized it graphically
and then that told us about how to
proceed so we can do this most
efficiently right they told us which
order we need to compute results so that
those results are ready for us when we
go to the next step and that is dynamic
programming okay so anytime you have
this kind of recurrence relationship
where the inputs are integers lay them
out in a table in a line whatever some
grid and that should give you some
insight into what order II should be
solving these problems there's more to
this more benefits to this approach
because let's think about what the the
performance characteristics of this are
so we said we need to keep around this
whole table okay so how many entries is
that well if there's T time steps and s
States
it's just T times us right we can just
read it off this table directly that
would be hard to do from that
mathematical definition we had earlier
secondly what is the time complexity
well again s times T that's how many
cells we need to compute and then as we
saw here for most of the cells we need
to depend on
s previous sells so s times T times s so
to summarize that I write the space
complexity s times T time complexity s
squared times T right any questions on
this the idea was we just read this off
the table again visualizing dynamic
programming is what helps you kind of
gain these kinds of insights so just I'm
gonna go through a little bit of code
but again the it's really a translation
of what I've already said we might
represent our hmm with the three
parameters right and we need to have
maps that say like okay given this state
Y is the probability of entering that
state and so on we need to have that
representation and I'm just gonna keep
around the actual set of states that are
possible just so that they're easy to
iterate over and then we're gonna keep
around this concept of what is a
probability of ending up at some end
State right that's our V value right
which we here call P for probability and
then what is the previous state that led
to that point and for the very first
column of our table
that's just none but for every all the
other columns we're gonna have some
entry here right so we've got to keep
around two pieces of information and
just start off calculating that first
column you don't have to read through
all this but it is literally a
translation of that that equation right
but we're just doing it over a bunch of
states we're gonna now go through the
rest of the time step starting at one
all the way to the end we're going to go
through the possible states those are
the previous one no these are the ending
States
and we're gonna look at all the previous
states and this is notice we're
referring to that V those B values that
we looked at before and we're just
storing that value along with the
previous pointer okay I don't want you
to have to memorize this I once I
thought through this this procedure it
wasn't that difficult to actually put it
down as code because the table was there
and you just like think how do I iterate
through a table finally at the end you
look at the very last time step and look
at the ending probability that's the
highest and that's your best end state
and to recover the path now you're just
gonna follow this linked list right go
back to the previous state go back to
the previous state and so on of course
you should reverse it so you get the
order you care about right so let's look
at a couple of real-world examples we
talked about speech recognition but
let's dive into that a little more I
said that there are states that are
predefined and observations that are
predefined how do you really have this
kind of continuous thing that's a
waveform and how do you make those into
discrete observations that you can kind
of have in a table of some sort well the
answer is you look at something like a
25 millisecond window and you do some
kind of like you know transformation
that pulls out the the frequencies you
also this is where you have to put in
the information you have about your
problem domain that's really important
here another thing that this paper talks
about is taking those frequencies and
mapping them to what our ears would
actually hear and then taking the top
ones so that were really extracting the
most important piece of information so
this is basically feature extraction
alright and that gives us maybe a 10
dimensional vector or something and
that's our observation space
and we do this it actually the paper
talks about doing it every 10
milliseconds and so there's some overlap
and so on but that's the basic idea here
okay another one
biology computational biology this is
where I actually first encountered this
what you have is in DNA you have these
four bases nucleotides right a T C and G
and that is your thing that you're
observing right it's one of those four
things now it turns out that in a DNA
sequence not every part of that sequence
really codes for the proteins right or
the amino acids that make up those
proteins so there's parts called
exons that actually do something and
introns that don't do anything and we
need to figure out where those regions
are right and it turns out again built
bringing in some information from the
domain is useful because the probability
of seeing certain types of sequences of
these nucleotides is different between
the different different regions and also
the nucleotides in the coding regions
the regions that actually produce amino
acids they will come in triplets they
have to be like a particular sequence of
three nucleotides one after the other
that code for an amino acid so in our
case our ground truth are these three
exon states right they have to be one
two three one two three one two three
and so on and then the int intron States
right and then that we just use that to
infer the exon and intron regions and
again we needed to know what was our
probability of seeing certain types of
nucleotides in certain regions the last
one I want to talk about is facial
recognition this one was an interesting
one where
you start with these images and you take
out little you talk about the regions in
the images right so if you're looking at
a face well first you'll see like
forehead eyes nose mouth and so on and
you need to see them in that order and
different parts of the images different
pixel values that you'll see will map
more more frequently to forehead you can
kind of imagine that maybe a forehead is
more sparse right so and you do need
them to be in that order for it to be a
face so let's try inferring it well what
is our our features and what is our
grounds truth well features we look at
this image we take out a particular
slice of the image and we do this thing
called the KLT it's a type of
transformation in image processing that
kind of tells us a little bit about how
the pixels are distributed and what it
turns out is you take the top number of
those right and there's different
distributions of those those K values
that you get after the transform
depending on the different regions so
here maybe eyes it looks something like
this in the graph that you see versus in
the mouth region it looks very different
right so again just like in the speech
recognition example you might have
something like I don't know 10 a 10
dimensional vector as your observation
space and then your ground truth here is
just the forehead nose mouth etc okay
any questions about that just a quick
overview speech recognition is
definitely one of the places where it's
like highly highly used but these are
and biological applications are also
they also use HMS quite a bit I don't
know how much facial detection still
uses hmms but this was a cool
application that caught my eye
okay so that's all assuming we have an
hmm and we know those probabilities
right
so we assumed kind of we know what is
our initial probabilities our transition
probabilities and our emission
probabilities but what if we don't all
right how do we train it so given a set
of emissions we want to find the hmm
parameters that maximizes the
probability of getting those those
emissions okay and we'll talk about how
we incorporate multiple sequences of
emissions later but that's the basic
problem that's being solved here and
like I said I'm not gonna go into this
in too much detail but I do want to
briefly introduce the concept right so
there is an algorithm that starts with
the following we will initialize the
parameters either completely randomly or
if we can we will find use some prior
knowledge right so in the case of speech
recognition like I said one piece of
prior knowledge would be what is the
distribution of words in the English
language that will help you figure out
your initial probabilities and your
transition probabilities next there is
this expectation step and so just like
we did the Viterbi algorithm to find out
the most probable path up to a certain
point we will actually do something very
similar to find probabilities that end
in a particular subsequence and these
are known as their forward and backward
probabilities and we'll combine them in
some way to figure out kind of what is
the probability of emitting something
from particular state at a given time
and there are some equations that I
don't want to get into but we will
update our parameters based on this
right that's called our maximization
step and we just keep repeating that
process until we've not we're not seeing
anymore improvements this is known as an
expectation maximization algorithm and
in particular for hidden Markov
the particular algorithm is called bomb
Welch
that's what incorporates the forward and
prior prior probabilities it does have
problems with local minima so that's why
you want to make sure that if you can
initialize your problem
initialize your your parameters as best
as you can early on to guide it towards
the right solution and then there are
some generalizations that you need to do
in which you incorporate multiple
sequences and you would do that kind of
at the expectation stage so you're not
basically taking one hmm
training it on one sequence overfitting
to that sequence and then training it on
new one wiping out your work from the
previous one so there are some there's a
paper from I think like 1986 that talks
about that whole process hi thanks for
the good talk so you mentioned a couple
times that it is important that the hmm
parameters were integers can you
elaborate on those sure so I'm not
talking about the parameters of the hmm
the initial probabilities and things
like that I'm talking about these
parameters into this this recurrence
relationship right we want to define
something that we will calculate values
at particular time steps and for
particular States and that's what allows
us to create this kind of table that we
can fill out yeah and also I have
another sure question is so of filling
the hmm you would have to give it a
parameter as in how many state you want
to find right so can you like make it
non parametric as in like in the model
can an algorithm find the optimal number
of states yeah so in this case through
the algorithms I talked about I don't
know there's other ones but there is an
assumption that you've already modeled
your problem with some states and
ahead of time yes does it have to be
equally spaced in time tactically no
there is no requirement for that however
once you think about it in terms of an
hmm
you've converted from your
domain-specific like representation into
the hmm representation they are discrete
time steps so it's one after the other
there's no constitutions or something
like that so for example with the speech
recognition right yes we're taking every
10 milliseconds we're taking a sample
right even if you didn't take it every
10 milliseconds probably wouldn't work
as well but it still state a time step 0
1 2 3 4 okay in independently of the of
the lag or or spacing between the time
steps exactly yeah so you don't bring in
at least not in these examples you're
not bringing in any concept of the
timing information okay yeah into this
model understood thank you so I'm pretty
sure I'm missing something but if all
your states are predefined and all your
probabilities are predefined and the
times are defined
how are you iterating what are you
because I mean you compute once and you
already have your maximum right right so
this is where we get into this problem
right here right if you were just to go
forward right one by one you would have
to have information about what what's
coming later to determine what is your
best pick at this point right because of
like the way somebody was talking it
might have made sense probabilistically
to pick otter not otto but you don't
know that until the end right yeah but
you have all the states at step three
right so if I go through the table once
I still like get to the same maximum
that's ad like Oh termo right so I have
state zero being the O and the state to
being the turn yeah but that's not what
you wanted you wanted octo mobile that
was a better choice yeah in this case
right so you picked the wrong ones when
you went through that sequence once so
you'd kind of have to go through the
sequence multiple times incorporate
information about what's coming up later
to pick the right choices earlier on
okay does that make sense
no because I feel like you're going
through all the chains anyway you're
going to every iteration with every
possibility going through the table once
yeah so the way we're going through this
table assumes we've already framed the
problem in that like backwards weight
right if we were framing it in the
forwards way that arrows would all point
in the opposite direction right and you
could do that right but the important
thing is you just have to make sure that
you are not you're not repeating the
same calculations again and again when
we talk about all possible chains well
the first time step it could be any of
those states then the next one any of
those states so this is like a
combinatorial explosion right of
possible chains that we could have and
you can't explore all of them you can't
iterate over every possible chain right
so how do you make it so that you are
somehow incorporating all that
information but only filling out this
table once so two questions one you're
building up the table to do iteration
rather than recursion correct yeah it's
so that it's better on memory and it
doesn't affect the call stack or
something yeah okay sure and related to
the previous question if you're trying
to predict more you're building up the
table once but if you're trying to
predict like the last part automobile
the Beall part yeah are you redoing the
table or are you using the entire table
you have until now yeah you would
definitely like if you're talking about
one sequence that you're predicting then
definitely you want you will just just
keep filling out the table left to right
right you won't that's the entire point
of not reusing that work now if you're
doing speech recognition and you're
hearing a new sample these are all
completely new observations so you're
gonna have to fill out a different
different table because now you're
seeing different observations right this
is this table it has states and time as
parameters but not the observation and
so this table is for a specific set of
observations I just want to point out
one thing related to that first question
about converting recursion into
iteration there's a related technique
called memoization so what you do is you
treat it like a regular recursion but
every time you calculate some value for
some inputs you save it in some some map
or something and in certain cases where
you could throw away some of that
information like we said if we didn't
care about those back pointers then we
could throw away any column we're done
with right in that case it would be more
memory efficient to go through this
iteration approach how would you define
initial state probabilities for likes
and a few other examples like image
recognition or like coding regions and
in in in a DNA sequence sure that's a
good question
I I don't know all of the domain
specific I don't have that domain
specific knowledge but if you've
observed in your data that let's say you
do know some of your data from before
then you can use that to help you figure
out what or for example if you know in
the biological sequences that like you
have these types of amino acids near the
beginning of the chain right that could
help you figure out okay this is how we
usually start off with these types of
states like it's usually an intron or
exons
yeah so how many previous steps do we
take into account with this so in terms
of the actual mechanism of computing
things we're only looking at the
previous step right so one step however
when we look at the previous step we're
using the values we've computed up to
this point so in a sense we are taking
into account the entire path we might
have come through to get to that point
and that's how we get around that idea
of like looking into the future or
looking into the past we're capturing
and summarizing a lot of information
about about the past so does that mean
let's say for one syllable I want to
take into account previous two syllables
then it is like two times two four four
possible previous yes steps right
exactly so as you add more previous
steps that you depend on this does
increase the time complexity
significantly exponentially Thanks all
right Opik that was a fantastic talk can
we give him a round of applause
[Applause]